en el distrito local de docencia está
disponible una beca para profesores para
instalar un conjunto de cuatro
computadoras en sus salones de clases de
los 6.250 docentes en el distrito 250
fueron seleccionados aleatoriamente y se
les preguntó si ellos creían que las
computadoras eran una herramienta
esencial de enseñanza en sus salones de
clase de los docentes seleccionados 142
afirmaron que las computadoras eran una
herramienta de enseñanza esencial
y posteriormente nos preguntan calcula
un intervalo de confianza del 99 por
ciento de la proporción de docentes que
piensan que las computadoras son una
herramienta esencial de enseñanza ahora
pensemos en toda la población si
pudiéramos entrevistarlos a todos la
población completa algunos de ellos y
los clasificaríamos uno con los que
responden las computadoras son buenas
herramientas los que piensan que las
computadoras son buenas herramientas
y definiremos el valor de 0 para los
maestros que respondieron que no era
buena herramienta una proporción del
total de maestros habrá respondido que
es una buena herramienta esa proporción
se llama p y el resto piensa que es una
mala herramienta tendrá en la proporción
1 - p tenemos una distribución de brno
link y sabemos que la media de esta
distribución o el valor esperado de esta
distribución va a hacer p o sea no va a
ser un valor ni 0 ni 1 sino un valor ya
que no pueden responder algo intermedio
tienen que opinar o que es buena
herramienta o que no lo es así que el
valor esperado es algo intermedio la
media es igual a p y lo que hacemos es
tomar una muestra de estos 250 maestros
y encontramos que 142 de ellos opinan
que las computadoras son una herramienta
esencial
así que en nuestra encuesta de
250 muestras obtuvimos que 142
dicen que es buena herramienta que es
igual a 1 así que tenemos 142 1
1 142 veces y el resto es lo que sobra
108 dicen que no es bueno
108 opinan que no es una buena
herramienta que es igual a cero en
nuestra muestra
teniendo un total de 250 bueno y cuál va
a ser la media de la muestra aquí la
media de la muestra va a ser igual a 1
por ciento 42 más
0% 8
entre el número total de muestras que es
250 que es igual a 142 entre 250 es la
proporción de los profesores que opinan
que la computadora es una buena
herramienta de enseñanza vamos a sacar
nuestra calculadora para hacer esta
operación 142 entre 250 es igual punto
568 la proporción de nuestra muestra es
0 punto 568 así que es igual a 0.5 68 y
también vamos a calcular la varianza de
nuestra muestra ya que la vamos a usar
más adelante para poder calcular nuestra
confianza vamos a tomar los valores y
los vamos a multiplicar por nuestra
media restando la a-1 y elevando el
resultado al cuadrado y esto lo vamos a
dividir entre el número total de
muestras menos 1
así que es uno por bueno de hecho es al
revés vamos a escribirlo
por 100
punto 568 que eso lo tenemos de la media
de la muestra y lo ponemos al cuadrado
más el 108 multiplicado
por cero menos
0.5 68 al cuadrado
y dividimos todo esto entre
el número total de muestras menos 1
va a ser 250 menos uno
250 menos 1
nuevamente sacamos nuestra confiable
calculadora
y vamos a escribir todo esto usamos
paréntesis 142 por paréntesis 1 menos
0.5 68
y esto elevado al cuadrado más 108 x
abro paréntesis
0 - y bueno pueden calcular algunas
partes en su cabeza pero yo voy a
escribir todo explícitamente menos 0.5
68 al cuadrado todo esto dividido entre
250 menos son los 249
el resultado es punto 246
nuestra apariencia de la muestra y la
voy a escribir por acá la varianza de la
muestra
es igual a 0.2 46 y si obtenemos la raíz
cuadrada de esto la desviación estándar
de nuestra muestra va a ser igual
sacamos la raíz cuadrada aquí con la
calculadora raíz cuadrada de la
respuesta anterior es igual a punto 4 96
es igual a 0.50 vamos a redondear lo al
0.50 y esta es la desviación estándar de
la muestra vamos a verlo de esta manera
estamos tomando la muestra de una
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra que luce más o menos así
algo así y tiene una media una media
de la distribución de muestreo de la
media de la muestra y esto va a ser
igual que el valor de la media
que también va a ser igual a la
proporción de la población y esta es la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de la muestra la desviación estándar de
la desviación de muestreo de la media de
la muestra nos estoy dibujando aquí y
acá entonces la desviación estándar de
la distribución de muestreo y hemos
visto varias veces que es igual a la
desviación estándar vamos a ponerle
diferente color es igual a la desviación
estándar a la desviación estándar de
nuestra población original dividida
entre la raíz cuadrada del número de
muestras va a estar dividida entre la
raíz cuadrada
ahora nosotros desconocemos este valor
de acá
no conocemos cuál es la desviación
estándar real de nuestra población pero
el mejor estimado que tenemos al
respecto y eso le llamamos confianza
tenemos la confianza de que la media
real o que la proporción de la población
real va a estar en este intervalo
tenemos confianza pero no estamos
seguros al 100% porque vamos a estimar
esto de acá y al estimar esto vamos a
estimar este otro parámetro de acá si
esto pudiera ser estimado lo sería por
medio de esta desviación estándar así
que podemos decir que esto es aproximado
y si tuviéramos una distribución de la
muestra completamente loca esto ni
siquiera podría ser una aproximación
pero a lo mejor debemos escribir que
estamos confiando conociendo
en qué
la desviación estándar de
la distribución de la muestra será
aproximada a y en lugar de usar esto
vamos a usar la desviación estándar de
nuestra muestra la desviación estándar
de la muestra
0.50 dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de
250 a que va a ser igual esto
usamos nuestra calculadora tenemos
este valor de cada el resultado anterior
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de 250 y
obtenemos 0.0 31 así que esto es igual a
punto 0 31 y esta es una desviación
estándar
ahora nos piden una confianza del 99 por
ciento y la forma en la que yo pienso en
ello es si yo seleccionará de manera
totalmente aleatoria una muestra de
nuestra distribución de muestreo cuál
sería la probabilidad del 99 por ciento
o permítanme re frasear lo cuentas de
presiones estándares lejos de la media
deberíamos tener para llegar a una
confianza del 99 por ciento de que
cualquier muestra de la distribución de
muestreo estará en este intervalo otra
forma de pensar en ello es preguntarse
cuántas desviaciones estándares alejados
de la media de tal manera que cualquier
media que calculamos de las muestras
tomadas tenga un 99% de probabilidad de
estar por arriba o para abajo de la
media dentro de estas desviaciones
estándares
esto es lo que nos interesa lo que estoy
subrayando en verde el 99% de
probabilidad de que si elegimos una
muestra de la distribución de muestreo
de la media de la muestra caiga dentro
de estas desviaciones estándar es que
estamos indicando acá para calcular eso
tenemos que consultar en nuestra tabla z
por lo que queremos una confianza del
99% si yo quiero este 99 por ciento de
confianza al ver la parte superior esta
área naranja debería ser punto 475 ya
que si esta parte 2.475 esta otra parte
va a ser también punto 475 perdón
tenemos que calcular el 99 por ciento
así que quitamos esto y ponemos punto
ya que es el 99 por ciento de confianza
que queremos y así esta área es punto
495 de manera que esta otra área va a
ser lo mismo y sumadas nos va a dar el
porcentaje de confianza que estamos
buscando 16.495 en este valor en la
tabla z tendrá que ser punto 495 más
punto 5 que es el área que se encuentra
de este otro lado de la distribución
por lo que nos va a quedar punto 99 59
y con esta información podemos consultar
nuestra tabla zeta
para buscar puntos 9 9 5
encontramos más o menos por acá punto 99
5 o está pues este valor es el más
cercano que podemos encontrar
vemos esta coordenada este valor
el área acumulada que tengo en mi
distribución vamos a dibujar la bonita
aquí
esta es la media de esta distribución
este 2.5 indica las desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media
así que este valor es 2.5 de la
desviación estándar
así que esto es toda esta área que estoy
subrayando aquí en la gente
va a ser punto 9 951
lo que nos dice que esta área de acá
solamente que estoy coloreando en verde
va a ser punto 4 951 esta área más su
área simétrica en este otro lado de
estas decisiones estándares por debajo
de la media si se combinan punto 4 951
por 2 nos va a dar el punto 99 2 que
estamos buscando toda esta área de aquí
va a ser punto 9 92 aunque debemos tener
cuidado porque tenemos que agregar otros
dígitos acá para mantener la precisión
esta es 2.5 y el siguiente dígito de
precisión va a estar dado por esta
columna de aquí que movemos la pantalla
para ver y el dígito es punto 0 8 por lo
que esta es 2.58 de desviación estándar
si tenemos 2.5 acá y luego en esta otra
parte tenemos el punto 0 82 puntos 58
divisiones estándares por encima y por
debajo de la media lo que
y abarca un poquito más del 99% que nos
habían pedido en el problema así que
aquí tenemos un poco más del 99% de
probabilidades de que cualquier valor de
la media de la muestra caiga en esta
porción de la desviación estándar vamos
a ponerlo de esta manera hay
99 bueno de hecho es si multiplicamos
esto por 2 vamos a obtener un 99 0 2 así
que vamos a decir que es aproximadamente
una probabilidad del 99 por ciento
noventa y nueve por ciento de
probabilidad
de que cualquier muestra de que una
muestra aleatoria de la media de la
muestra esté dentro de 2.58 desviaciones
estándares de la media de la muestra d
la media de nuestra población de la
media de nuestra distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra que
es lo mismo que la media de nuestra
población que a su vez es lo mismo que
la proporción de la población de pep y
sabemos cuál es el valor de aquí al
menos tenemos una aproximación decente
aunque no sabemos exactamente cuál es su
valor nuestra mejor estimación de este
valor es esto de aquí arriba por lo que
podemos reescribir esto diciendo que
tenemos la confianza tenemos la
confianza porque estamos usando una
estimación aquí tenemos la confianza de
que hay un 99 por ciento de probabilidad
de que una equis aleatoria una media de
la muestra aleatoria esté dentro de
vamos a obtener este valor usando
nuestra calculadora por lo que vamos a
escribir 2.58 por nuestra mejor
estimación de la desviación estándar de
la distribución de muestreo
punto 0 3 1
esto es igual a punto 07 esto vamos a
redondear lo vamos a ponerlo a punto 08
está dentro de punto 08
punto 08
de la proporción de la población
o se puede decir
o puedes decir que tiene la confianza de
que la proporción de la población se
encuentra dentro del punto 08 de la
media de la muestra es exactamente el
mismo enunciado siquiera un intervalo de
confianza la media de la muestra
encontramos que era punto 568
encontramos que era punto 568 por lo que
podemos reemplazar esto y lo vamos a
hacer
puedo borrar esto de acá
se va
y cambiar esto por punto 568
por lo que tenemos una conciencia del 99
por ciento de probabilidades de que el
punto 568 esté dentro del punto 08 de la
proporción de la población que es lo
mismo que la media de la población y que
es la media de la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra y
para hacerlo todavía aún más claro
podemos intercambiar estos elementos de
manera que si esto es el punto 08 de
esto aquello estará en punto 568 de esto
por lo que estará dentro de
vamos a cambiar esto punto 568
y esto vuelve más a un intervalo de
confianza ya que tenemos la confianza
del 99 por ciento de probabilidades de
que esté dentro de punto 08 de la media
de la muestra del punto 568 nuestro
intervalo de confianza es punto 568 +
menos 0.08 y eso qué significa el rango
va de punto 568 más punto 08 en el
límite superior punto 648 y en el límite
inferior si restamos punto cero 8.568
será punto 488 tenemos una confianza del
99% de que la proporción de la población
caiga dentro de estos dos números otra
forma de verlo es que el porcentaje real
de profesores que consideran que las
computadoras son buenas herramientas
está entre obtenemos la confianza del
99% de probabilidades de que el
porcentaje real de los profesores que
les gustan las computadoras está entre
punto 4 8 8 en él
el 48.8 por ciento a 60 y 4.8 por ciento
esto responde la primera parte de la
pregunta la segunda parte dice cómo
puede cambiarse la encuesta para centrar
el intervalo de confianza y mantenerlo
en el intervalo del 99%
bueno pues debemos de tomar más muestras
al hacer esto nuestro estimado de la
división estándar de esta distribución
va a disminuir ya que el denominador va
a aumentar por lo que todo esto va a
disminuir y la desviación estándar va a
ser menor cuando veamos las desviaciones
estándares con 'la más o menos en el
rango este valor va a disminuir por lo
que debemos tener más muestras